In 1997, a massive, gray cloud of gas and
smog settled over the ordinary town of Daleport,
New England.
Phone lines were cut off, and any attempts
to enter the town were met with failure.
There was a complete and total blackout of
information coming in and out of Daleport.
Whatever was occurring it was anything but
normal, and clashed with the town’s easygoing
and peaceful atmosphere.
An anomalous event of this size and scale
was impossible to miss, and naturally caught
the attention of the SCP Foundation before
it did the outside media, who would report
on the mysterious occurrence and draw unnecessary
amounts of attention to the town.
The Foundation was lucky enough to maintain
a hold over the situation little over 3 hours
after it had begun, and they already started
their usual cover-up story operations, keeping
the situation in Daleport well away from the
public eye.
Still, they were unsure of what was occurring,
and what they were dealing with themselves.
If they were going to get to the bottom of
this mysterious smog covering an average New
England town, they were going to be safe,
and have to play it resourcefully, as the
SCP Foundation is known for doing.
The status of Daleport’s residents, whether
they were alive or dead, was completely unknown,
and so the Foundation began their rescue efforts.
A containment perimeter surrounding the town
was established, and relevant witnesses outside
of the town were detained and amnesticized,
with convincing cover-stories already being
deployed.
For the Foundation, even an entire town undergoing
an anomalous event was something they were
well-prepared to deal with, having handled
similar situations multiple times over the
decades.
The Foundation began its research on Daleport
by observing what exactly the cloud of smog
covering the town was.
The Foundation wasn’t keen on sending its
personnel, even the so-called disposable D-Class,
to their death, so the first exploration into
the cloud was carried out by an unmanned ground
vehicle operating under the callsign ‘UGV-1’.
This unstoppable carrier was equipped with
all the stops, including atmospheric sampling
sensors, audio-video recording equipment,
and a open-circuit biological sampling instrument,
which contained skin tissue and several live
brown rats, whose reactions would indicate
to the Foundation whether or not the smog
was safe to be exposed to or not.
The ground vehicle departed, and when it returned
about a half hour later, it brought with it
a whole host of data about the gas covering
Daleport.
As it turned out, the smog was composed of
sulfer, nitrogen, and carbon oxides concentrated
at a level where irritation would occur upon
contact with humans but it wasn’t lethal.
Neither was it anomalous, as the samples the
vehicle carried in with it were unaffected
in any anomalous manner.
The video recording displayed a flat, empty
wasteland inside the gas cluster, with little
discernible features.
After a certain point, radio communication
with the vehicle became degraded, and the
Foundation returned the carrier to the town’s
perimeter.
As more resources and supplies arrived on
location, the Foundation ramped up its research
efforts.
This time, two D-Class were sent into the
gas cluster, both aboard another ground vehicle
carrier.
This time, the truck was equipped with a higher
wattage radio transceiver than that of the
first one, which the Foundation hoped would
be enough to maintain communication throughout
the anomaly.
At a kilometer from the boundary, the D-Class
unboarded the vehicle and were asked to remove
their protective suits.
They experienced no anomalous effects from
exposure to the gas, but medical telemetry
showed that one of the D-class was having
difficulty breathing.
The duo reported the same flat, featureless
terrain the first vehicle’s recording had
captured.
When radio interference occurred again, the
Foundation pulled the vehicle back, and the
two D-Class were recovered safely, with no
abnormal effects occurring as a result of
being exposed to the gas.
Still, there was no indication of what was
actually occurring in Daleport.
It was only that lifeless, gray horizon, and
the Foundation wanted answers.
A third expedition was carried out, this time
manned by Mobile Task Force operatives equipped
with all of the latest gear, as well as several
large vehicles.
The vehicles split up, but communications
quickly pointed out differences between the
team’s surroundings.
One spotted an upward incline, while the others
only saw the same terrain as before.
Minutes later, the incline team reported that
they were going down an incline.
The team that hadn’t seen the incline reported
that they were now seeing it, and that they
were following the other vehicle downwards.
Another team noticed red and blue patterns
in the sky, while voices on the radios began
speaking in an unknown language.
After minutes of radio interference, the Foundation
picked up the sound of a firefight, with mobile
task force operatives giving wildly varying
descriptions of the attacking forces.
Whatever was happening was incomprehensible,
and for whatever reason, the Foundation was
entirely unable to communicate through their
radios.
After around 30 minutes of noise, an unknown
voice gave a mysterious, gibberish-filled
message to the Foundation.
It’s a little silly to hear, but there’s
certainly some strange undertones within.
The voice said:
“Blargh, I am Ssvlsrr, the Shivering Mist.
I am the n'ghft currently covering the town
of Daleport.
While traversing my ftaghu, your men have
been attacked.
Some have become n'gha, but the rest are in
safe hands.
Evil has been summoned to this town, by a
society of hlirghh.
The worst shall be contained within me by
vulgtmm and tharanakk, but the town and its
people will not remain unaffected.
A great battle shall rage and a victor must
be decided.
In time, those who can stop the ehye will
be here in time and see the hlirghh fm'latgh.
Please do not send any more soldiers into
me as I cannot keep them from the shogg.
When all throd before the victors, I shall
leave and the shugg will be yours again.
I hope you shall survive it.
Y'hah.”
It was clear that something had taken over
the town of Daleport, and that this mysterious
voice, while threatening sounding, was apparently
protecting the people inside.
It mentioned that the Foundation’s men were
in safe hands, and that evil had been summoned
to the town.
The Foundation didn’t know what to make
of the message, or if they could trust the
entity that made it.
But they didn’t have much of a choice.
They attempted to send more unmanned operations
into the town, but they were unable to reach
their destination, somehow always winding
up back where they started shortly after departing.
After a week and a half of fruitless expeditions
and no new information, the gas blocking the
town of Daleport dissipated completely, leaving
the town accessible and able to be explored
fully by the Foundation.
A containment crew fully set-up a perimeter
around the area, with secure cameras and an
entire facility on the outskirts of Daleport,
named Area-37, to oversee and support the
Foundation’s research inside the town, which
was now officially categorized as SCP-1936.
With the gas now dissipated, the Foundation
began to investigate the anomalous effects
left in its wake.
The town itself was altered, with buildings
physically differing from their previous states,
and a large portion of them having become
topologically inconsistent.
There were rooms that would appear bigger
or smaller than they should be, with some
growing so small after they had been entered
that they trapped occupants inside and prevented
them from moving, resulting in a number of
unretrievable Foundation personnel becoming
stuck and lost inside the anomaly forever.
Other doors would lead to different locations
at different times of the day, or corridors
that led to multiple locations at the same
time despite only leading to one.
These difficult to describe spatial anomalies
were so dangerous and unpredictable that the
Foundation forbade any exploration into SCP-1936
without explicit authorization.
But while the town itself was affected, what
about the people inside it?
The normal people who were caught up in the
anomalous fate of Daleport, what happened
to them?
The Foundation was unsure, and while no survivors
were found within the town itself, a large
number of human remains of Daleport citizens
were recovered during the exploration efforts.
Most of these remains demonstrated anomalous
properties, presumably gained as a result
of the devastating anomalous disaster that
plagued the town a week prior.
Some of the remains the Foundation recovered
were incredibly strange.
Such as a smear of entrails found alongside
a small plant that gave out a constant flame.
The pile of viscera picked up radio transmissions
from up to six miles away, with sound being
created through vibration of tissues.
Another was a torso embedded in the wall of
a building.
Slight movement of the torso was visible when
investigating personnel spoke, and blood continually
manifested in mid-air, fifteen centimeters
above the torso.
On the main street of the town, several corpses
were discovered with their flesh, skin, and
bone all removed from a circular portion of
their foreheads.
Skin and brain tissue surrounding their wounds
had undergone severe charring.
Outside of the public library, several floating
torsos manifest at a certain time each day,
simulating the motions of running alongside
the road.
After three minutes, the torsos attempt to
leave the road and fade out.
A young woman’s body floats steadily upwards
when any force is applied to it, regardless
of the force’s direction.
The body is currently suspended 57 meters
above the ground, floating over Daleport.
And these are just some of the strange anomalies
found within SCP-1936.
While it’s unknown what happened to these
civilians, their bodies were clearly affected
by whatever occured the week prior while the
Foundation was unable to access the town of
Daleport.
Something in that strange, anomalous gas triggered
a highly destructive event that had grave
consequences for ordinary people, and the
Foundation was none the wiser as to what it
was.
Still, they continued their search of the
area, and over the next few weeks, they discovered
a number of recovered materials from the wreckage
and debris of SCP-1936.
The first were a series of written documents,
composed by the town’s previous inhabitants.
These were recovered from laptops and journals,
but read in that same, nonsensical tone that
the mysterious voice spoke in during the Mobile
Task Force’s expedition.
One note said that the writer was running
out of canned food, and that there was constant
screaming coming from outside their house,
and something trying to break into it.
The note talked about the town’s reverend,
described as having ‘too many spaces in
him’ who was walking past the writer’s
windows and ranting about total nonsense.
The note also read that the writer was fearing
that, as they put it, ‘one of the big guys’
was coming their way, and that they could
hear the pounding, constant sound of drums.
But one note remains consistent, found in
multiple locations throughout SCP-1936, predominantly
in public toilets and stitched into the internal
organs of the Daleport resident’s bodies.
It reads “I am so sorry that I could not
save you.
Signed, Pangloss.”
The Foundation had heard rumblings and rumors
of the entity known as Pangloss, who was supposedly
a god with a helpful affinity for humanity,
but there was no concrete evidence pointing
towards the being’s existence.
Whatever happened in Daleport, was Pangloss
trying to stop it?
The message certainly reads that way.
Surveillance footage from a gas station painted
an even more terrifying picture.
An ordinary gas station cashier was doing
his job ringing out a customer’s items,
when the window next to him smashed open,
and an impossible-looking, tentacle-filled
entity made its way into the building.
The tentacle creature lashed out at the two
of them, brutally murdering the customer with
the force of the impact of its slippery, writhing
appendage.
The cashier hid behind the counter, but the
footage shows the entity also making its way
behind the counter, and the gruesome visual
of blood splattering the walls behind the
register as the entity quickly took the cashier’s
life.
But then, mysteriously, an individual enters
the gas station, wearing a bowler hat and
a waistcoat.
The footage distorts as they enter the shot.
Then, their face is revealed.
Instead of ordinary features, like a mouth
or eyes, they have a triangle branded into
their skin.
The tentacle entity moved back in fear of
this well-dressed individual, clearly afraid
of them.
Then, a series of multi-jointed appendages
burst forth from various points on the individual’s
body, and they lunged forward, attacking the
tentacle-entity.
The footage cuts off there, with the individual
throwing the tentacle creature through the
wall of the gas station.
Whoever this individual was, it was clear
that they didn’t take kindly to the rampaging
tentacle entity.
Some Foundation researchers began to speculate
that the individual was Pangloss themselves,
who was trying to save Daleport as best as
they could, but there was obviously no way
to be certain of the mysterious person’s
identity.
More footage showed a car crash outside of
a public library, which resulted in a spectral,
translucent entity breaking free from the
broken lamppost that the vehicle collided
into.
The car’s passengers immediately ran, but
the ghost-like entity chased after them.
This continues until the ghost emits a large,
blue shockwave of unknown energy, which passes
over the people, turning them completely transparent,
and causing them to fade away.
The Foundation recognized that it was another
mysterious, surreal entity rampaging through
Daleport.
Clearly, whatever happened here was anything
but normal.
Another collection of footage, this time focusing
around Daleport’s town hall, depicted the
building in complete ruin.
The roof was collapsed, the front doors were
missing, and the entire structure was toned
in a blue-violet hue.
In front of the building was a convoy of vehicles,
civilian trucks and cars, as well as the ground
vehicles of the Mobile Task Force squads that
went missing after they were sent into the
anomaly.
It was clear this footage took place shortly
after the Foundation attempted to enter the
gas surrounding Daleport, and lost connection
with the task forces that were sent in.
The footage shows the Foundation soldiers
as well as the civilians of the town fighting
against another strange looking entity, this
time shaped like a fractal structure.
Eventually, they retreat into the town hall
building, narrowly escaping from the strange
creature and directly into a circular blue-violet
vortex.
After all of the civilians and personnel have
escaped, the phrase ‘PANGLOSS GRANTS YOU
SANCTUARY’ is burned into the stonework
above the town hall’s entrance.
It was this footage that gave the Foundation
a better idea of what occurred in SCP-1936,
though the strangeness of the visuals didn’t
clear much up.
Whatever disaster happened in Daleport, whatever
resulted in these absurd, hostile entities
being unleashed upon the town, was actively
combated by Pangloss, the deity who was trying
its best to move civilians to safety.
But one question remained.
If Pangloss was transporting civilians to
safety, where did they wind up?
Why did the Foundation not discover any survivors
inside Daleport?
Well, their answer came a few weeks later,
when in a shocking turn of events, 94 live
civilians and nearly all of the missing Foundation
personnel manifested inside the Area-37 facility.
Pangloss’s emergency escape method worked,
and the civilians were confirmed alive and
without harm.
It’s not very often that missing persons
are actually recovered in the Foundation’s
line of work, so hats off to Pangloss for
managing to do some good in this horrifying
situation.
Interviews with the recovered individuals
indicated that they all suffered memory loss
regarding the events of Daleport, so unfortunately,
there was no new information to be gained
from their recovery.
But inside the anomaly, Foundation expedition
teams uncovered more documents and pieces
of evidence, this time referring to a cult
named the Victory Society, which the Foundation
began to believe were the cause of the mysterious
gas arriving over Daleport, and the town’s
destruction.
Little is known about the Victory Society,
but it is believed to be a religious organization
that was localized to Daleport.
One note, recovered from the body of a Victory
Society member, was a list of things that
the cult needed, which included a strange
and ridiculous combination of items, including
two trout, a bottle of milk, beetles, ice,
dead bodies, human eyes, and assorted souls.
In the margins of the note, there were more
personal thoughts, which the writer lamented
the difficulty in acquiring some of the objects.
Another note was found on the inside of a
book, this time detailing a great religious
battle between gods and entities that the
Foundation had never heard of.
Once again, it was written in that lofty,
nonsensical tone, detailing an all-encompassing
mist that would descend upon the world, which
would prevent those from entering the location
the text described as the place where an event
known as the ‘awakening’ would occur.
If this text was to be believed, Daleport
was the center of a battle between incredibly
powerful extra-dimensional anomalous entities,
who clashed together with little regard for
the residents of the town.
It seemed that Pangloss, the entity who saved
the civilians, was just trying their best
to move as many people as they could to safety,
away from the havoc of the surreal battleground
that Daleport was becoming.
More documents, this time from the Victory
Society’s Reverend leader, detailed the
cult performing a ritual.
Again and again, the reverend stated in his
notes that the ritual was for, in his words,
“The good of everybody”, and that “the
victor” would “walk from the rubbles of
man and restore clarity to those who remain.”
The notes also included a transcription of
a speech given by the reverand, in which he
addressed the Victory Society cult with haunting
premonitions of what was to come.
His voice painted a harrowing picture:
“Brothers and sisters, we come together
to bid farewell today.
It has been an honor to work with you all.
I could not have hoped for a better group
with which to secure the future of mankind.
From the dawn of time, terrible impossibilities
have spawned from the darkness between stars,
not hating life, simply being indifferent
to it.
We are as ants to these abominations, these
demented Gods.
They are so far above us that we are but insects.
Accordingly, we shall look as such.
In order to gain the forgiveness and favor
of the Gods, we must learn to know our place
before them.
Each of these things seeks dominion over the
laws of reality itself, imposing the nature
of their twisted existences upon stars and
planets and people.
The only answer to this threat?
These Gods must be destroyed, the slate wiped
clean.
We could not do this, by no means, no.
But we cannot allow these things to exist.
A kingdom cannot have a billion kings.
We cannot kill the Gods, no, only a God can
kill a God.
We will bring them here and bind them.
Bind them until their bloodlust is sated,
until all but one is dead.
Always a single God remains: the Victor, who
returns to whence they came as the only God
remaining.”
And with that, the mystery of Daleport was
solved.
The Victory Society cult sought to wage war
between the gods of the universe, until one
victorious being would emerge.
The town of Daleport was used as a battleground,
with all of the anomalous effects occurring
as a result of the combat between these terrifyingly
destructive entities.
And if you’re familiar with the deities
that go toe to toe with the SCP Foundation,
you know these guys aren’t a joke.
The Scarlet King and his legions of devilish
followers, the almighty Broken God, and the
mysterious, benevolent Serpent of the Library
are just some of the powerful religious entities
the Foundation has researched and cataloged.
And if what came to Daleport was anywhere
near as powerful as those examples, it’s
a wonder the rest of the world is still here
after the fact.
Another piece of surveillance footage, taken
from in front of a church in Daleport’s
center, depicts these violent deities in combat
with one another.
Beings of massive size and incomprehensible
shape battling with one another in an ordinary
suburban town.
The victory society’s goal may have been
incomprehensible and difficult to understand,
but the Foundation will never forget what
happened in the town of Daleport, and the
destruction these impossible entities caused.
But a single question remains.
We know that Pangloss transported some survivors
from the scene, but what was the result of
the battle?
Why happened?
The Victory Society mentioned that a single
entity would emerge victorious from the battle,
but who was it?
Which god was so terrifying, so powerful,
that it slaughtered the others and crowned
itself king amongst the anomalous pantheon?
Perhaps some questions are better left unanswered.
Now go watch “SCP-001 - The Scarlet King”
and “SCP-2217 - Hammer And Anvil” for
more terrifyingly destructive deities from
SCP Explained!